Bus driver, my friend needs to pee.
Don't do it, Pete!
This is what happens when you pee on the bus.
Me and my boyfriend, we're actually going down to LA.
Maybe you should just come with us.
She's five foot four, blonde.
That's her.
Hey!
I know he's the hero of Star Wars.
But who exactly is this Kirk person?
She's out there alone.
She's a very resourceful girl.
Give it to me!
Give me my notebook back!
Where am I?
You're at the hospital, you hit your head.
She jumped out the window!
How did she get away from you people?
What language is that?
It's Klingon.
Your sister is one of the most complex and creative people I know.
People have their own lives and after a while, those lives don't include you.
Captain!
There's only one logical direction in which to go.
Forward.
Light.
It can travel for millions of years before finally reaching its destination.
Do you know how hard it is to write something...
...because the story you wanna tell means so much to you?
It goes lonely and alone, hoping that it will reach someone.
That's amazing!
So, what happens next?
The unknown is there for us to conquer, not to fear.